[Applaudissements]
lieu
patrick à tout le monde rêverait de se
faire photographier par les on n'a
jamais l'impression qu'il fait des
photos techniquement
[Musique]
les warrants des gens très bon c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait des photos
naturellement élevé
c'est un visionnaire de la mode et de la
beauté
[Musique]
aucun photographe qui depuis tant
d'années est au sommet comme ça dans ce
métier quand je vois une photo de
patrick dans un magazine je dis ça c'est
parti
[Musique]
m
à
c'est ici à sainte adresse dans la
proche banlieue du havre que tout
commence issu d'un milieu modeste c'est
dans cette ville portuaire du nord-ouest
de la france que patrick demarchelier
passe toute son enfance
voilà
e
c'est l'âge habité pendant de l'âge de 4
ans à 17 ans 18 ans l'habitabilité la
balle sans le drôle comment l'éviter au
grenier aux élèves et la calandre à
commettre comme cuisine avec magna et
cinq frères le plan organisé par le
divorce est donné par jean et au
beau-père pour sergio de trouver d'être
une vieille amérique par me donner cette
caméra
tiens caméra souffler kodak durer comme
ça je vaccine les photographes et donc
je suis venu voir d'un côté on bat et
gtc malgré le triste il faut les
portraits le mariage et je suis entré
comme stagiaire au laboratoire le soir
pour apprendre développer et ses
retouches et négatifs et agrandir les
tirages et j'ai commencé la photo fait
d'être portraits d'amis comme ça qu'elle
est pas qu'ils sont assez boutonneux à
ses 15 16 ans alors je retouche sur les
boutons c'est ces photos et puis je les
revendais les photos
[Musique]
lorsqu'il revient sur les lieux de son
enfance
c'est avec un brin de nostalgie qui
évoque ses souvenirs et puis un jour on
étouffe voulons pas voir une partie et
je suis parti à paris et après ils
prennent leurs boîtes noires chez
publicis à faire du des tirages noir et
blanc et de la presse du parti
d'assistant d'infraction et gérad écho
dans une piscine et monde et un ans
après aux six mois après était en
faillite il bousille l'adresse après
avoir et je fais quand vous levez
apparaît vous voir c'est tout le travail
de mes graines photos saisies par des
caméras dans le logo havre et le coup de
pot personne de travail et surtout de ma
vie très bon face aux reds photo 32
caméras et autres passe porte des
mariages et dans cette liste grise de
naïve et un à christie écoles de
mannequin je suis allé voir en société
et m'ont vu tout prix comme ceux de
grâce à murray de mes photos et je suis
retrouvé les cales de mannequins savais
que j'avais un petit studio à
laboratoire et 20 à 38 paroisse qui
devait faire un petit bouc
[Musique]
l'épisode s'appelle écoles de mannequins
dont je pense à regarder un peu la mode
de la séance photo au mont saint michel
pour un grand magazine de mode sous le
regard avisé de carine roitfeld la
rédactrice en chef avant que celle astic
rien n'est laissé au hasard c'est la
7ème marché de bram boo delà de la halle
à contribuer à la caisse 3 paritaire
[Musique]
avant de démarrer c'est très très dur à
paris ou cdd des périodes qui le
demandent
j'ai pas en une chambre de bonne sans
eau sans salle de bains lavabo et je
vais prendre la douche municipale
renforcée dans l'avesnois les douches
municipales on paye j'ai pris 1,20 à
l'époque de vincennes comprend une
bouche et du menton que vous l'avez tous
les samedis et jeanne moreau était
d'obtenir dégueulasse que je vous
l'avais j'ai des courses d'endurance de
te reprends besoin de te l'avais dit toi
et j'habitais à pigalle et je marchais
jusqu'aux alpes à ce que les frites et
moins chers et meilleurs que dans le
coin de pigalle présentoirs et par
exemple j'achète un quai de métro
ils sont arrivés train de revendre mais
mais mais mais mais ils mettront pour
bouffer les doigts
enfin semaine j'ai pu en
majorées bim métro pour acheter un
sandwich frites
[Musique]
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
patrick je venais d'arriver à paris
c'était en janvier 1968 à des castings
j'ai passé un casting comment aller
travailler avec patrick demarchelier
il n'était pas aussi connu que je
n'avais aucune idée de la personne que
j'allais rencontrer et voisines et waka
c'était à côté du moulin rouge studio où
il faisait froid et il m'a demandé
d'enlever mon manteau pour pouvoir faire
des photos et je disais et non mais non
je garde mon kit macao tonnes alors elle
m'a mordu au bras mais on m'a toujours
dit parce que j'étais très jeune
tu sais à paris est une ville dangereuse
fais attention mais en fait nous sommes
devenus de bons amis patrick m'a pris
sous son aile il m'a fait découvrir les
grands restaurants
je n'étais pas d'argent c'était très
sympa maintenant nous sommes amis depuis
40 ans vous ai-je eu de carrière c'est
marrant c'est que j'ai pas démarré et du
succès de suite j'ai été trop long des
marais j'ai bien travaillé et de
l'argenterie d'oeil j'ai très vite ali
beaucoup en allemagne au bout et c'est
pour berry d'allemagne frei dynamique en
italie n'est pas pour les journaux
précisent comme bob quoi et je trais
post-trade tous les trucs l'espèce
rennes et strasbourg nord et j'ai très
bien ma vie et mes cheveux sont un peu
bloqués en europe
en france je me sentais un peu j'ai
d'autres choses à faire que de rester là
dedans
[Musique]
voilà le mot
cette expression je redis juillet gérald
frydman
j'ai horreur de ça
[Musique]
très bien s'est lâché on s'est très très
bien j'ai lu d'allemagne en italie mais
j'étais pas bien encore que je sentais
que j'avais envie d'aller en amérique où
j'avais l'âge précoce de la mairie qu'il
avait été un rêve y avait deux régionaux
cible bas et j'avais cette impression
qu'en restant ici j'avais parle déjà été
bloqués assad avait un certain niveau
ici
[Musique]
français né en région parisienne
installée à new york depuis 1975
son histoire est celle d'une success
story comme les aiment les américains
[Musique]
j'ai passé là bas pour sont restés assis
- ans et je pensais pas que je fallait
pas vous engueuler important et donc
c'était très dur en arrivant là bas
celle qu'un bouc charge de travail et l
époque chez les médecins formés à
l'étranger arrivé comme ça n'était pas
eu dans ce que ne parlent pas la langue
du tout je trouve du travail un petit
peu juste ravi de jouer un jour par mois
alors que son rôle serait toutefois qu'à
travers semaine de donc la mocheté
rétrogradé je travaillais ans moins un
jour par mois comme ça et
j'ai appris l'anglais qui doucement
regardant la télévision et puis vint la
masse a démarré tout doucement mais
c'est un pays très
positif c'est qu'ils tireront sans le
progrès le rendu le monstre avec une
banque ça va toujours demeurer au mieux
ses archives et tout va tout est classé
lassé des meubles plein de trésors
et c'est chris hughton
entre deux photos
la katiba
à la beauté des photos montrent le
curieux alors que l'école où j'ai trouvé
un journal le glamour qui venait beaupré
travail je serai très peu ce sera une
fois tous mais tous les mois par une
fois par mois pour vos débuts
après 13 semaines petit magazine et
approcher la mademoiselle d'un journal
n'est qu'un américain pas toujours
photographe moi de là jean marc et je
suis vraiment désolé pour eux et
américains m'appeler à - non après et
c'est là que ça a démarré très fort
volume et casser un peu la démarche de
tous le rêve de tout photographe c'est
de faire du voc et faire du box et de
fallait grande campagne dans le luxe
c'est d'être reconnus et patrick lahaye
il l'est depuis depuis 15 ans 20 ans 30
ans c'est quelqu'un qui est donc est
allé au sommet mais qui est resté et ça
c'est unique
[Musique]
je m'excuse exprime donc fait l'idée se
démettant de mettre à l'aise c'est
important que les gens sont à l'aise et
n'essaye pas est ce naturel
ils deviennent beau il devient de
voleurs caractère ou alors leur
expression le body language aussi de 17e
et se sentent bien et donc faut pas les
casser les les jeux ne pas les mettre à
mon image ne plaisait pas de trou une
image aux yeux que je n'ai que
s'exprimer même sans qu'une sage ne veut
parler d'économie et n'importe quoi faut
parler pour leur excès commis par l'
agence relaxe plus malin que si vous
aviez vous-même leur faut de l'action
sans rien ils s'angoissent complètement
il risque vingt ans ils parlent ils sont
sont figés il ya de mal à l'aise et je
ne bougeais bien faire
les six jeunes sambriens photographier
en général parce qu'elles sont plus
naturels là elle pense - avec l'agent
pense trop est quelqu'un de plus âgé
camille âgées s'inquiètent
qu'est ce que je vais avoir quel objet
aujourd'hui je suis mis à jour dès que
plus de complexes on s'amusait bien
jouer le maintien jouer que les nier
qu'il faudra s'est amusé de faire des
photos je me souviens de la première
fois c'était il ya peu près quatre ans
c'était à l'occasion d'un shooting pour
vogue italie c'était une photo simple et
j'étais nerveuse de la faire il est
juste venu vers moi m'expliquer ce que
je devais faire
elle m'a rendu le travail beaucoup plus
et je me sentais un peu comme à l'école
tu sais quand tu travailles avec lui tu
apprends à chaque séance un peu plus sur
toi
en plus ils maîtrisent chacune des
choses qu'il fait
[Musique]
petit
dans les rues redonner log n'oublie
jamais ses origines modestes
parti de rien il est aujourd'hui à 65
ans l'un des plus grands photographes du
monde
il a réalisé des centaines de
couvertures pour les magazines les plus
prestigieux photographié les plus belles
femmes du monde et ses portraits
artistiques sont régulièrement exposés à
milan
mexico ou comme ici à new york
la première fois que j'étais avec
l'afrique c'était pour une campagne de
gars et je me souviens
m installé sur un tabouret et donc lui
dire sa caméra et on parlait et j'ai
parlé avec lui donc et le client et on
parlait entre colère et blagueur et tout
à coup une bimbo masse est bon et je
regarde si ces banques et ces boues il
me dit ça y est c'est fait et je m'étais
pas aperçu qu'il était en train de
prendre des photos pendant ce temps là
et il a cette spontanéité de la vie de
prendre le moment de pain en ferrain
quelque chose qui n'est pas il le vit et
il est surprenant
[Musique]
changement de décor saint-barthélemy
petite île française des antilles
découverte par christophe colomb à 230
km au nord ouest de la guadeloupe
c'est dans cette île que patrick
demarchelier acheté il ya vingt ans une
maison dans laquelle il revient
régulièrement
[Musique]
ici on vient où ils refusent de son
apparence les porte déjà des fruits
travail se passer un mois l'ol redoutent
février/mars novembre caussinus énorme
en kippa de saison donc je vais t'en
veux évidemment quand je me sens pas
bien je fatigue est ici et c'est la
tranquillité et doigté turbo ça fait
comme à spa pour moi je dis bien nagé tu
veux te proposer tel massage du midi
pour que vous ayez été agréable moi je
suis français mais aujourd'hui hier et
que ces extraits seulement 3000 new york
il faut trouver un petit coin de france
une telle supermarchés français hersant
français culture et ils mélangent
français américains italiens est appelée
dans le tunnel de paix du monde et
collectionneur d'art contemporain
il a une passion pour warhol et parce
qu'à mais le plus important pour lui
demeure ses trois enfants et sa femme
suédoise toujours aussi discrète épouse
est née plus de 30 ans
dans cette île des petites antilles le
regard du photographe est toujours en
alerte
certains de ces clichés qui ont fait le
tour du monde et sa réputation ont été
pris ici dans sa maison de robes de
monsieur biya
nadia robe de galliano c'est d'y croire
qu'elle fait dans l'himalaya
ce village les bancs du tibet très très
haut l'attitude zahia un coup de vent et
le verre la roja n'a pas bougé le temps
des photos spontanées sera gelé la
famille de nomi en studio à new york
dans la migration éclats de vie elle est
tellement belle et tellement j'ai sa
première couverture du vogue français 2
a préféré d'albine noir ce que deux
français l'époque elle avait 16 ans
étaient elles n'ont pas toujours d'être
interviewés de chaussée près que deux
françaises la marque et universel chi le
proxy qui tu es fais un cinéma ni beach
en temps chez lui c'est madonna qui
attendait je travaillais pour le bonheur
toi je ne vis pas au monde et chaque
photo est un peu souvenir un moment
c'est un moment qui a passé avec les
gens et c'est souvent moi très agréable
donc tu regardes plein de souvenirs aux
bravos structure garde tient sous la
photo rappelle ce moment qui revient à
toi c'est madonna qui est l'absence
revanche déjà très bien ces photos là on
travaille pour une pochette de disque en
studio et on fait par le studio et le
vinaigre et madonna était prête à temps
d'élection de chiens sauf à tracer ma
route
c'était un moment intéressant
quand
la lumière sacrée la photo l'ambiance
bout de choses il belle lumière c'est le
matin très tôt au lever du soleil et au
coucher du soleil c'est vrai c'est très
jaune dont tu peux corriger ça disons
que de lumière comment que je fais ou
pour faire général doit s'adapter au
sujet pas de lumière pour tout le monde
tu as des gens qui sont bien crado donc
ce bien que les deux mêmes niveaux que
dépend des yeux de la structure du
visage les qu'ils ont de ce qu'on veut
trouver aussi ce qu'on veut faire et que
votre sortie ressortir qu'il est
mannequin une fois j'aime bien les faire
leur plein soleil par exemple avec des
ondes forte lumière forte qui les
rendent un peu méchant paix
c'est quelqu'un qui ne qui adore le
challenge donc pas par rapport à un
problème posé si on pose un problème
patrick on a ces photos-là faire on n'a
que deux heures il va il va faire des
très bonnes photos d'archivés en noir et
blanc que l'album tu vois pas les petits
défauts de la peau aussi d'aller au feu
rouge avec des couleurs de peau de très
belles que voit on aurait blanc doux à
lesparre est déjà il ya un peu de
mystère noir et blanc que je préfère je
gagne mystère d'un projet
tu vois je ne dis pas ça que c'est celle
déclenchée les pattes arias bouge inhalé
ces quatre pattes la ville parisé ne
peut pas marcher quelque part ils
indiquent sans l'inr sous les rencontres
des gens qui qui côtoie que ce clinton
où sa femme ait jamais été suivies du
monde est mélangé
c'était la maison blanche ah oui c'est
vrai alors que j'étais un peu effrayé
parce que l ai pas vraiment très belle
ml j'ai été choqué de voir qu'elle était
extrêmement photogénique
quand on la voit en tant que photographe
un peu peur
[Musique]
bon
la révolte appelle pas la maison blanche
par exemple que m'étonner quoi parfois
c'est pour soulager la femme de reagan
nancy reagan
parce que l'impressionnant tu vas là-bas
la sécurité pourrait là dedans entre le
truc tout le truc se trouve dans la
maison blanche la grande pièce avec la
fin du présent qui arrivent et qui l'a
photographié son portrait s'amusant et
aussi le préfet que diana m'a appelé
pour la londe photographier c'est assez
impressionnant l'on se doit et j'ai
c'est aussi parce que l époque tu sais
que de la royauté anglaise très grave de
l'anglais donc sa première fois qu'elle
a appelé quelqu'un d'étranger à français
dans l'antre autres pour bien
photographier donc je suis allé dans une
campagne avec le prince charles était la
leur
et puis londres sa fille cette photo est
très gentil jeu servi à déjeuner elle
même
tu vois pas reculer devant elle servait
à table chez la gaule assistants et fait
faute et qu'elle et ses enfants sont
tous et dont la marque peu après pour
faire supporter officiel avec le sa
couronne le portrait officiel d'elle et
là je vais trouver un coiffeur
fantastique à maquiller à sa médaille de
londres et mike edwards et la saison
préférée a titré jusqu'à sa mort et les
la paix la norvège partout et on l'a
coupé les cheveux longs la roma qui y
est sublime
on a fait un pas nouveau look plus
moderne a été fantastique et la beauté
c'est son sourire j'ai sur la maison
sourit à la souris avec la vie
extraordinaire doit se revoir à dieu que
tu oublié voix et je faudra fait trois
quatre fois et beaucoup d'acteurs qui
veulent pas être photographiée par là
parce que ça faisait un petit défaut et
c est patrick trouve le bon côté il vous
fait parler pendant cinq minutes et puis
tout d'un coup il a vu l'animation il a
vu le moment où la lumière attrapez
votre
votre intérieur et c'est ça qui est beau
c'est pas simplement être une belle
personne c'est aussi ce que vous avez à
l'intérieur qui ressort à l'image parce
que l'image ne pardonne pas à l'image et
la photographie ce moment que vous avez
donnée avec un sourire avec une émotion
et saissac patrick ces captures est en
réalité quand on est photographié comme
filmées par un metteur en scène un
photographe qui vous aiment qui vous
apprécie c'est un peu comme faire
l'amour avec avec la caméra
c'est un échange sans très sensuelle qui
a entre entre le modèle et son
photographe ou le modèle son metteur en
scène c'est vraiment c'est vrai qu'il ya
une énorme séduction et c'est très
agréable d'avoir quelqu'un comme patrick
derrière une caméra parce qu'on sait que
le regard qu'il a sur vous et le regard
d'un homme qui vous apprécie et qui sort
justement le plus beau et le plus
sensuelles d'une femme à l'abri des
regards indiscrets sa barthélémy abrite
jalousement ses stars johnny hallyday sa
famille titien aiment s'y retrouver et
recevoir leurs amis
non ça formidable et photos elle est
belle java
[Musique]
la fiction à présent échappé de belles
merveilles pour
vous
moi j'ai jamais fait de photo avec lui
c'était mon rêve ça s'est fait comme ça
vraiment tout naturellement en cinq
minutes sans préparation sans maquilleur
son coiffeur et les photos elles sont
magiques elles ont une beauté dame
incroyable et c'est la force de patrick
c'est de faire des photos comme ça
par magie la magie de son travail la
magie de son regard sur l'être humain
qui la fatigue et la faim était fatigué
et mais ce que je peux faire
ancien tueur français était bien là mais
elle vous met ensemble au computer et la
branche et de genève la gazal supervalu
super véloce elle est géniale regard
qu'on pose pas avec nous il fait des
photos de vous il vous prend et nous
capte naturel et je pense que c'est bien
c'est comme ça que les sujets qu'il
photographie sur les lieux et il sait
rendre les gens beaux c'est toujours
derrière pour son retour quand on se
regarde photographiée par c'est parce
qu'on se dit après tout on n'est pas si
mal que ça
japon
sauveur
c'est ça ta force c'est de tirer de
chacun d'entre nous le meilleur sur
vannes et besoin de se farder d'en faire
des tonnes
je joue hier il était comme tout à
l'heure j'étais sobre sommes sommes
passés il t'amène au contexte du décor
sobre d'aisé que pour rendre belle pour
ce sont une très belle photo c'est pas
la peine d'être maquillée d'en faire des
tonnes de nickel
contrairement à la peinture ou les les
peintres ont le temps et de la retouche
mettez-moi entier a imaginé un sujet lui
en espace de quelques secondes il a déjà
vu le sujet c'est déjà ce qu'il a
exprimé et il a donné une force
je vais lui a régné et les ti certes une
force terrible à la photo et le rendu
est saisissant parce que ce que moi j'ai
vu parce que lui a vu avec son sont un
objectif qui l'a rendue avec son
objectif ça strictement rien à voir
il a tiré le meilleur de deux de l'être
humain le meilleur de johnny son
charisme il a un coup d'oeil très très
malin très très espiègle dans les yeux
on le voit aura centièmes de seconde
moi je sais il a ça dans le ventre mécha
pas de lui il pouvait le lui saisir ça
ce que nous nous connaissons en une vie
il a saisi en une seconde centièmes de
seconde
quelqu'un de particulier patrick à une
personnalité incroyable et qui a un
talent énorme qui est un magicien de
dell de la lumière de la photo et qui
rend les femmes belles parce qu'il sait
les regarder différemment il un joli
regard sur les femmes sur l'être humain
en général et sur la beauté de l'âme sic
ont parfois quelqu'un qui n'est pas bon
il arrive à le rendre beau parce que
il est la personne en valeur on se sent
bien quand on est quand on est regardé
par lui et quand on est filmé par lui à
travers sa caméra
en tout
[Musique]
bon
à 2h de los angeles au sud de la
californie et dans le désert de mots jav
séance de travail un peu particulière
[Musique]
patrick demarchelier est concentré il
attend une des plus grandes stars de la
chanson française qui lui a demandé de
faire la photo de son prochain album
[Musique]
arrive en compagnie de laetitia et
daniel angeli son photographe personnel
qui les suit depuis toujours
on savait pas c'est super
whilst alice la styliste l'événement
dans le kent
[Musique]
m
google exprimèrent les du caractère non
c'est pas ça pour qu'il soit à l'aise
tout le talent est souvent mieux la
députée depuis l'accès au tunnel
le portrait j'aime bien les photos d'un
des visages bien des gens qui
s'expriment peu avec les mains mais
j'aime bien le nouveau bijou sur les
bijoux pièces dans les mains du
personnage sauf le problème je viens
c'est par exemple ce personnage très
intéressant
allez on plaque
lasseube à l'ombre ces ballons à l'état
de l'union
bien généreux très bien super génial
mais j'aime bien le studio extérieur ça
dépend ce qu'on fait là pour un truc
pour un chanteur qui a porté en tournée
que de sortir un disque
c'était un peu plus de rêves dehors
qu'un studio on sent le même si des gros
plans on sent qu'il dehors on va un peu
le désert on veut pas trop ça fait un
peu c'est plus de magic saison 2
[Musique]
non
nous sommes tous noirs des questions sur
la photo xd race mai de la photo
cela s'explique pas tellement pour moi
croit une photo était fait mais
spontanée c'est un instant et gb que les
gens je prendrais m'explique à la photo
de toi j'ai bien que les gens voient ce
qu'ils veulent voir la photo
[Musique]
on
quand je vois une photo de patrick dans
un magazine je dis ça c'est patrick
mathieu c'est patrick healy à tous de
lui dans son travail c'est un grand
artiste parce qu'il ya tant de photos
que tu regardes sans reconnaître
l'auteur dominici alors que quand tu
regarde une photo de patrick d'helmut
newton
david hearn de brest berwyn peine ou de
démarches liées
je sais que cette heure c'est ça qui en
fait le style est beaucoup plus
sophistiqué maintenant et plus
perfectionné attitude mais le personnage
et sa photo est toujours la même
patrick est quelqu'un c'est un caméléon
aussi c'est quelqu'un qui a réussi par
rapport à son style à s'adapter tôt
touchant à tous les changements de la
marne patrick ses pains branché c'est
quelqu'un de moderne mais qui est
intemporel c'est à dire que la photo de
patrick elle reste al'inverse de
beaucoup de choses à la mode qui se
démode puisque mode des modes ça change
beaucoup
patrick reste ces images vous pouvez les
regarder dix ans après elles sont
toujours moderne et c'est ça aussi qui
est unique c'est patrick
quand il travaille à los angeles patrick
demarchelier loge toujours au beverly
hills
l'hôtel mythique des grandes stars du
cinéma
son fils victor 23 ans devenu son
assistant et de tous les déplacements
c'est par la cik deux fois transmettre
son savoir un des enfants c'est
sympathique de pouvoir le d'avoir
étoiles en voyage ça peut poser est
celle très amusant ne préfère décrire le
monde en un an
et puis un tour du monde pas du mans et
ces bas devant la halle l'oeil d'un
jeune sur le mont c'est très bien de
l'avoir date où il découvre tout et ses
copains comme un nouveau né qui
découvrait le la ville doit c'est très
drôle
il rêve aux seins nus mais reste aux
archives le reste en chine australie
n'dori australie et les pédales au maroc
par exemple une banque est sublime maroc
et il est venu à postuler mais ça il est
[Musique]
parce qu'elle d'engin est un ami fidèle
de patrick demarchelier
c'est une figure incontournable du monde
de la mode
on le surnomme le magicien des photos
car il les retouches avec élégance sans
que cela ne se voit la règle on est
presque on y est presque
donc ça c'est un peu son à ce qu'on a
fait ils ont à nouveau patrick c'est
vraiment un des photographes qui arrive
magiquement à extraire de quel que soit
le sujet qu'il photographie que ce soit
une chaise
bizarrement ou une fille ou un or il
arrive à rendre les gens très beau il
regarde la personne mais sa lumière
sculpte son visage comme un peintre fait
et tout de suite ça se met en place
elana est tellement
un laser ils aiment la beauté il aime
les femmes donc et puis rend les choses
faciles c'est jamais difficile avec lui
tout est très rapide c'est quelqu'un de
qui voit tout de suite
c'est ce qu'il aime la démarche de test
rsa serait le ca serait la spontanéité
départ et je fais les gens n'ont pas le
temps ça merde et je met en confiance et
j'ai prévu une manière très positive
très optimiste il sauterait et sur de
sombres heures pot que le gras fier et
je suis assez rapidement ne pas trop
regarder en sueur général de ses sept
passes haut débit je suis assez
rapidement c'est psychologique la photo
de serre des gens comme ils sont leur
caractère défaut de marquer deux essais
de cédric demarchelier pascal d'engins
au rendez vous
journée importante pour un événement
hors norme
la préparation de l'hommage que le petit
palais à paris a décidé de lui rendre
pour la première fois
432 ces photos y seront exposés au
milieu de toi les collections
permanentes
c'est pour lui une consécration dans les
statuts avec des portraits dans les
landes dans le vert
[Musique]
la légende veut aussi rentrés par là
au petit palais le jour j approche
[Musique]
les préparatifs se poursuivent avec
fébrilité et concentration
[Musique]
lyon paris dans des gares musées dans
ses photos pas ou peu de rides les
visages et les corps semble épargné par
le temps patrick demarchelier une vision
personnelle de la beauté et à sa manière
i la sensualité la photo de mode
en attendant la grande soirée
d'inauguration où sont attendus de
nombreux invités patrick demarchelier
poursuit ses séances de travail ce jour
là à paris il s'agit de photographier
une personnalité dont la photo sera mise
en vente aux enchères au profit d'une
association bienfaisance
bien dans le fauteuil on le fait c'est
un peu l'objectif d'allonger comme ça
joue un peu
après ça ce serait sans danger
je pratique ici un peu vraiment comme ça
la sublime et bien être un joli hein
j'adore tes lumières du jour
cette discipline premières photos que
j'ai vues de patrick demarchelier dans
les grands magazines du monde entier
vont tout de suite frappé par cet
équilibre assez subtil entre le naturel
absolue et la sophistication et
l'élégance donc en fait c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait des photos naturellement
élégante ce qu'est ce qui est très rare
parce que il y avait très très belles
photos très sophistiquée et il ya des
magnifiques photos naturelles mais mais
l'assemblage de deux frères âgés au club
merci bonjour voyage bonne journée à toi
voilà donc voilà il ya cet assemblage de
naturel et de d'élégance qui est qui est
très très rare pour moi qui qui embellit
le modèle quels qu'ils soient je pense
qu'il rend les femmes très belle et je
pense qu'il ya autre chose qui est
fondamental c'est que dans sa manière de
faire la photo il ne sacralise pas et ne
mystifie pas son travail et il ne fait
que le rendre fluide en quelque sorte
et alors on se sent jamais crispé quand
on a photographié par lui et ne se sont
jamais figées
donc ça c'est très importante pour la
beauté je pense que la beauté n'est pas
figé
kazim de son fils une très belle femme
c'est une femme debout de qualité qui es
tu vois c'est une beauté et une
intelligence tout ressort c'est une
femme intéressant tu vois c'est très
intéressant
photographiée par les photos uniques
aussi et puis elle a de la vie elle est
la beauté département fait beaucoup de
physique et pottas terriens qui ressort
c'est quand on dit on fait les gains
après quelqu'un ils sont beaux ces
panneaux de plastique de fois ces petits
potins un vieux trèbes aussi les fameux
et très belle si c'est pas seulement la
beauté bottin toute chose à ajouter
j'adore ce coin c'est pas souvent au
cinéma
j'échange pas s'exprimer un peu
d'échangés mais non j'ai 30 ans je me
dis oh je me dis quand même pas trop
qu'on était 2e 50 à 10 quand on est déjà
trop comme ça comme sa cible il est
certain qu'il a donné vie à une femme je
parle en général qui peut être un petit
peu trop parfaite un petit peu trop
figée et dans ces photos elle et elle
elle est toujours belle cette femme mais
jamais jamais dont ceux sur esthétisme
dans lequel la main peut parfois se
réfugier pour des raisons de perfection
en quelque sorte et dans des photos de
patrick demarchelier finalement les
imperfections aussi sont très belles et
donc ça c'est très rare de pouvoir
garder son humanité tout en ayant
quelque chose de ravissants quand même
je pense que c'est ça le le secret des
grands photographes est sûr que c'est un
des plus grands photographes du monde et
de notre époque oui je suis le petit
palais c'est sublime beauté sublime pour
une très libre installation sera lille à
faire ça c'est fantastique
et l'idée d'exposition qu'ils auraient
quitte à lui séduit je mets pas mais le
salon ça c'est drôle c'est utile
d'expulsion permanente
il faut tout voyage à tripoli pas l'ex à
la voyager partout entre tableaux et
tout a besoin passe-partout génial
[Musique]
ce qui est merveilleux avec patrick
c'est qu'il n'est pas seul hub et il ne
juge pas quand il prend une photo il
tire le meilleur de la situation
d'autres photographes vont refuser
certains projets qu'ils ne les inspire
pas plus que ça ou parce qu'ils n'ont
pas suffisamment de talent mais avec
patrick que ce soit un jeune designer
winstar il fait preuve du même
enthousiasme est aussi positif quand il
s'agit de les photographier tout le
monde l'intéressent et ça ce sont des
qualités remarquables
c'est une grande joie que de travailler
avec lui
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien variété des choses je
suis trop de mode deviens maire d'anjou
et reportages s'emmerde en danger mais
c'est très mélangées ya eu deux
portraits de fraude modes de
le nul aussi des animaux où j'ai bien
aimé ça à plat mélangez bien et
mélangeant plus notre mère doit
[Musique]
il a une vraie élégance mendel élégance
aussi une beauté physique mais il a une
élégance de l'âme et ça c'est très
important c'est ce qui est d'ailleurs ça
ressort dans la qualité de son art
parce que je crois que tout va ensemble
se calent tout est donc quand on a cet
élégant cela existe deux de rayonnement
qui là aussi il lui le projet dans tout
ce qu'il fait dans la vie
qui sait quelqu'un qui donne beaucoup de
lui-même et donc il était mais c'est
c'est juste qu'ils le soient et qui soit
honoré comme il est maintenant avec
cette exposition formidable sur son
oeuvre
parce que le mérite de frontin grand un
maître de notre époque
[Musique]
oh